welcome back to part two of every minute
someone explodes we got all the boys but
this time we have Chandler everywhere I
thought we would make it through the
intro without so it exploded anyways if
you saw the first one right here you
know the gist
every minute one of us randomly explodes
our goal with this series is to beat the
ender dragon we're going until that
dragon dies whoa all right we need to
make a chest all of our chests got blown
up in the last one who's all over chest
last time we did this it was just me
Carl and Chris but this time we have
Chandler so the odds of us blowing up
whoa look oh did you not die I didn't
die the odds of us blowing up is lower
so hopefully we can get more done hey
I'm back
hey bud well I feel like we need to
build an explosion-proof base somehow
obsidian probably somebody's luck go was
that you car yeah right as I said
somebody's about to explode if you're
under water do you explode land that's
what we one time so what if we cover our
chest in water so they can't bring I
think it still affects it though no I
think water blocked explosion it's the
only way to do it is test it everyone
come here and stand in the water Chris
come up here I didn't die again thing
you're a wizard Harry not my fault it's
the server don't blame me
all right guys stamp up water first
science test is to see if but we're all
gonna explode
Oh see look Carl wasn't underwater and
it didn't break I went flying okay so
our science experiment worked
whoa oh dude I got I got your stuff I
got it all right here's what we need to
do we need uh incorporate a buddy system
stay far away from each other but if you
blow up like the other person can help
you Chris me and you are buddies wait Oh
world so close what are we doing I have
all the stuff here let me get all the
stuff that's my stuff I'm here to lead
this team urgency is key
we need more ion I'm gonna explode all
right I just smell it it's good I was
about to say it's gonna be me all right
good we got 20 iron cooking boys I'm
gonna go get some water
I'm getting hit Chris I'm about to half
a heart take my stuff if I die oh I got
it get all the iron and bring it to the
furnace quickly I'm fighting the
skeleton right now somebody's gonna die
soon this is so much easier now that
Taylor's here because we explode way
less oh it was me so what do we put
water
that yes so now we're good oh dude it
stares me so hard every time make sure
you have a vet call
I don't you sleepy I do get sleepy ah
okay I blew up look Oh guys diamonds
diamond get it and get out of there now
I'm getting out I'm trying I'm trying
I'm trying
yo there's six there's six total let's
go oh don't die
Oh Oh it was Carl Carl where are you I
got it guys I got it I'm gonna back it
going in blind they're still there guys
were good no make the pickaxe I need a I
need wood I need wood oh wait Carl bring
it down to our base oh it was me it was
me it was me
we also need to start making like iron
armor and stuff like that we need to
figure out how much help we need to
survive the explosions you'll be right
he'd be left also we cool cape spider Oh
[Music]
lapis enchantments baby we can do blast
protection I had a bunch of stuff on me
I cannot figure out where it was cuz I
have done them I don't know they said
that I love hey Carl what do you have 64
torches oh alright how many diamonds did
you find six diamonds which means two
pickaxes so we're gonna take those picks
mine obsidian don't go to the nether
okay I'm about to go now ah okay thank
you Jimmy now I have 60 seconds to mine
some obsidian so what's about a blow-up
Carl I feel it no don't put that juju on
Carl okay it was me it was me me I got
my first Obsidian block guys we did it
you're doing great Carl
Wow I will eat no snicker I couldn't
write nothing thanks Chris did you get
this stuff I'm getting I'm getting oh no
don't worry I put all the stuff into the
chest and didn't blow up the chest how's
Chris gonna watch and then not tell me
that there's a creeper right behind way
really you died by a creeper and he
didn't give you a warning number one I
was eating and I my mouth was full
number two Carl had I have not been
there I wouldn't have grabbed your stuff
for you and then put it into the chest
our base is waterproof boys
joy okay let me know when everybody dies
okay when somebody explodes let me know
this is gonna be okay
Oh Chris did you get the pickaxe did I
get the frickin pickaxe you bet your
butt I did yeah
I've been blown up in a while so I think
it's gonna be me next
I'm gonna take some iron and I'm gonna
make a set of iron and see if I still
die oh come on it's only me it's only me
guys I'm full iron on let's see if like
when I explode if I die I'm not gonna
live I gave up a little while ago I've
just been watching Carl dig and just
getting his stuff when he dies oh I
didn't die all right guys get iron armor
we just figured it out
Oh all right one time did you actually
find diamond and emerald let's go are
you by the way I just finished getting
all the obsidian we need those all the
diamonds what I get for no oh wait don't
worry it's fine look at all the craters
here from all the time sweep explode hey
guys I'm making the thingy Oh Chris died
and you had iron armor mm-hmm
wait so it doesn't save you nope me
Jimmy we're feeling so safe it blew a
chunk out of the ground
Wow you know what doesn't have a chunk
blown out of the ground what our
brand-new nether portal we need a flint
and steel boys flint and steel flint and
steel okay I have steel oh I can't
believe you why would you spawn on me
wait channa you exploded on him he just
jumped on me I didn't know I was gonna
blow up where the honk is my diamond
pick or Chris picked up someone ran by
me
no I didn't pick up anything yes you did
Jimmy look and I in the toy Chris picked
it up Karl he's trying to get me to lie
to you why are we still
just suffer Jimmy has it Jimmy hazard
Carl pick who do you think has it I saw
Chris in pretty crazy well that's funny
because there you go what Chris you were
in the crater spread out spread out
spread out spread up ah that's what you
get you bully
alright guys meet at the base lets me in
our safe space I've never been in here
oh my lord [ __ ] at Chandler give me my
pickaxe I don't have it dude I swear I
don't this time Chris I don't have it
wait we need to go back up there and get
the time in pink wow I actually do need
to find my own diamond pick them
can I have my stuff back can I have my
stuff back wait what are you talking
about Carl my diamond pick oh you mean
the one that's in the freaking chest why
don't you check the chest that's what
it's here for you idiot okay editor play
back every tide checked it like seven
times cuz I'm OCD
you've got it
are we getting to the nether we just
need Flint guys guys guys guys
oh thank you Chris Oh puts the chest
that way I'm looking for the grapple oh
my gosh Chris could you not blow up five
inches from me why were you standing
near me
I just mean there's no gap on the map I
just got my stuff back
why don't we still blame this I found
gravel wait is this crap it just says
crap oh I got a fight okay Chandler give
it to me Carl
throw it to me throw it to me run oh my
it line it we're gonna do it now you
have to craft a flint and steel real
quick blue wires in the chest 30 seconds
till someone explodes again Jimmy are
you getting it yeah all right all right
hurry
Taylor count one three oh four five six
seven
that's gonna be me 15 16 17 who's it
gonna be
19 Oh get away from any 23 25 it didn't
happen it didn't happen Jimmy we did it
they may have a bucket they can put some
water on the ground I'm emptying
everything in the chest I'm visiting the
nether hold on I want to go hold on we
should all go together
all right guys after someone explodes we
all rush to the nether if this X pawns
have chicken our luck will change all
right well this is gonna suck get away
from the board oh you did it
new nerds I was running hey Jimmy come
on we're doing it all right let's go in
breach breach breach you pushed me
oh my gosh Chris yeah I'm not going
through it we can't go through why is it
not working
[Music]
[Applause]
stop jailor help me come help me [ __ ] a
bit blockhead you're gonna blow up get
his pickaxe his picker I have you just
needed back out of the game alive wobba
reset the server Oh Jimmy that stuff
stuff stuff stuff stuff stuff stuff
stuff stuff stuff stuff Jimmy let's do
it
hey let's go you guys have fun without
me I'll just sit over here we're going
deeper bye Jimmy what do we do wait will
you stop oh you're gonna I didn't mean
to why don't we bring in time and
pickaxes into the nether that's a good
point
that's a good point oh yeah
gah got blown up the Frick is the base
yeah all the diamonds and the diet the
pickaxe on me why because people died
around me Oh people died around you
hi there you go it's been many long
hours but we finally made it to the
nether boards how do you guys feel yeah
we did it we went deeper I literally did
everything we've been through a lot boys
for the journeys just beginning in the
next episode we will get to the end and
then the episode after that we will slay
the ender dragon nope slay the ender
dragon on three one oh all right slay
the ender dragon on three one two three